out of the holiday travel rush and it
was a chaotic weekend for many more than
5 400 flights were canceled from friday
to sunday because of bad weather and
other air travel issues
and drivers had to pay record high gas
prices this morning the national average
for a gallon of regular is 4 dollars and
62 cents
elise preston joins us now from a gas
station just outside new york city elise
good morning
good morning jim gas prices continue to
set daily new records and are up more
than 50 percent from just a year ago but
that hasn't stopped millions of
americans from traveling at levels we
haven't seen in years
it's a tough time for many americans
eager to travel again you're going to
spend more money getting there paying
for gas
than you actually are you know to enjoy
your visit in california home to the
nation's highest gas prices a regular
gallon of gas costs more than six bucks
i'm staying close close to home in the
air there was more stress for travelers
with over a thousand flights canceled in
the u.s over the past two days mostly
due to severe weather and ongoing
staffing shortages this year the number
of air travelers is close to
pre-pandemic levels but the average cost
of a domestic airline ticket this summer
is up more than 45 percent compared to
last year definitely makes you rethink
like how much is it worth it this
memorial day stretch is expected to be
the busiest for travel in two years and
despite already eye watering gas prices
experts believe we may not have hit the
peak what does that mean for memorial
day travel if gas is on average
461 across the country well it's going
to mean that they're going to have to
dig far deeper there is still the
possibility that we could see the
national average go even higher i would
say or estimate sixty percent odds of
the national average hitting that five
dollar gallon mark at some point later
this summer
still for many americans breaking out of
two and a half years of pandemic life is
worth the cost and has been a big
motivator to spread their wings we
haven't traveled since i covered so it's
just nice to get out enjoy a little
break
while many drivers are paying close to
five dollars a gallon many experts think
that the national
average could go even higher this summer
but that would take an exceptional event
like a hurricane this as we're seeing
less refinery capacity and a relatively
strong demand michelle
elise thank you